there's been wild celebration here in
Istanbul with literally hundreds
possibly thousands of people Gathering
outside his residence to not only hear
his victory speech but to set off
fireworks and to basically celebrate
this historic third term that he's won
there was really no question no doubt in
uh certainly the erdogan's Camp's Minds
that he would win we spoke to him in the
first round and he was extremely
confident about his prospects and in
fact when I asked him when I asked him
about uh
whether he would accept the outcome
whatever the result he took great
exception to be questioning what he saw
as his record over the past 20 years
there's no doubt though that he he's
facing
[Music]